you're already getting one
you know you're already getting one
[Music]
okay i'm ryan pauno i'm from toronto i'm
the host of pillow talk with ryan and i
came to new york for the jake paul fight
which got cancelled on our way here now
we're at barcelo
cooler than the jake paul fight
and i'm here to answer the internet
would you rather give the first 90 of a
[ __ ] or the last 10 percent
you know what i think
that i'm
i would be good at sucking dick
so
first 90 for the first 90 percent that's
not 15 minutes i'm not
so i'm in and out 90
bang would you rather be falsely accused
of murder or never be able to stop
coming
load it up baby girl load it up
you know i saw that guy what's his name
the guy that's uh no we're gonna miss
wrestlemania what's up making a murderer
oh yeah yeah oh yes yeah [ __ ] being that
guy i want to come
i also feel like falsely accuse him or
you can beat it right yeah so that's
another reason so but he was he's still
in prison
yeah he's [ __ ] that guy is [ __ ] and
no one cared it was cool i was on
average we gotta get a go fund me obama
obama no one cares would you give up an
inch of penis length for an inch of
height
i ain't got no inches to give out baby
girl
also six three but even if i was uh as
tall as uh
her dear friends you know a little five
foot gang keeping all the dick i got
would you rather everyone in your
girlfriend's office want to [ __ ] her or
nobody want to [ __ ] her that's a [ __ ]
good question that's a really good one
you know what
i get off to
like i like dating only fans girls i'm
like go masturbate to my girl i get like
an ego from being the one that has sex
with her you know i turned me on you
jerk off i [ __ ] so i like the [ __ ]
thing but a lot of my insecure loser
friends would say no i want an ugly
[ __ ] and you can't say me for that one
okay
if you were gay for a day who would you
want to bang
johnny sends the goat
but you have to bottom for him that's
the kicker oh myself
[Laughter]
would you rather always come prematurely
or never come at all this is a good one
i have more of an issue with getting my
dick up to even just play the game
while i'm playing
you know i can i have stamina so
never come at all i'll stick to what i
do because i actually have to fake
orgasms sometimes it's very embarrassing
but stick to what you know if it ain't
broken don't fix it would you rather
live your life as is or be a billionaire
but you have to blow a dude every day
joey come give me your dick
[Laughter]
would you rather [ __ ] the hottest girl
celebrity who has a dick or a vin diesel
with a [ __ ]
wow
that's a good one one word
family
would rather magazines be the only porn
you could use or have to sit on the
toilet when you have to pee i've done
the magazine porn jerking off i i i
actually used to be a playboy guy no
it's all good and people say they p
sitting down i'm a stander
i stand next to the only thing yeah
after that
oh it's forever
let me take a seat when i pee i'm gonna
sit when i pee
are you a wet or dry masturbator
dry
dry i don't
come on
you sick [ __ ] that use lotion every
time
chill bro enough we get it you're a
horny like
it's a lot i've tried it it's a lot of
because the lotion lasts what it rubs in
minute 46 seconds tops
i mean like you got to do more lotion
it's kind of cold too the white lotion
then when you're done you feel like a
[ __ ] loser you can't even clean up
properly your hands all dirty it's
really moisturized and then it leaks
down the left side of your balls because
i'm a lefty
it's the whole debacle
tight grip we're good would you rather
have sex with someone who only washed
between their knees and their belly
button or someone who only washed from
the knees down and belly button up
only washed between
so they
here or here
give me the clean vagina i'll take the
clean [ __ ] plus comes first
armpits
put some boots would you rather never
have any buffalo sauce food again love
buffalo sauce or only be able to
masturbate to pregnant porn
you would come up with this [ __ ] eh you
guys are sick [ __ ] that's a good one
i'll stick i'll take my blue cheese
would you rather orgasm every time you
hear all-star by smash mouth or hear
all-star every time you orgasm
hilarious yeah that's funny i'll take
the second one the latter you know all
that glitters is
would rather go three straight summers
without drinking or live a full year in
antarctica what is that
what's antarctica i'm going i got a
drink where's my high noon what is
antarctica south
didn't know there was a south pole did
you who lives there
there's penguins and polar bears it's
like three signs no that's the north
pole
the south pole i'm a little tipsy off
the high noon myself if you couldn't get
hard for a year my life and you finally
got your first boner would you want to
jerk off or [ __ ] a chick vr porn jerk
off next question would you rather give
up porn or sex for one year honestly
sucks i swear to god i know that's weird
but seriously i don't even like sex that
much
i'm on a hot cold streak right now i
ain't mad at it my only fan's login
didn't work
bigger issue would you rather shoot webs
like spider-man or have claws like
wolverine both come out of your dick and
then you guys put a picture of it
the web come on that's too easy you got
to get rid of the web you got to put
something like uh yeah laser don't we
all shoot web out of her dick uh oh i
don't like that face
would you rather have one giant dick for
an arm or have all your fingers be dicks
one jungle or have all your fingers be
dicks
that's hard can i do ask the audience
what do you guys think you know what arm
dick
you could do some porn with that and you
could be
you could blow up internet sensation
would you rather have a good hand job
from your grandmother
or a bad hand job from your grandmother
[Laughter]
oh that's hilarious you [ __ ] you sick
[ __ ]
i you got
you're already getting one
you know you're already getting one put
it this way okay i asked this to my
friends i said you go to prison and the
biggest guy there says you're dead today
or you have production for your life you
got to suck my dick once so you have to
are you going to try to give them a good
[ __ ] or you're not gay so just give
them a [ __ ] one that's a good one
too you know
so it kind of goes down to that and then
my dear friend kalang said
do you want good production or bad
protection in prison
going with the good hand job
[Laughter]
thank you for watching anthony internet
with ryan poundle make sure you
subscribe to the channel do that
comment below what other celebrities you
like to see and make sure you hit the
little bell to get a reminder when we
drop a new episode